neulich auf diesem kanal florida und
zahnpasta die ganze wahrheit und upload
jetzt dürfen alle zweifel beseitigt sein
doch dann ist selbst öffentlich
rechtliche kollegen warten voller
verdummung durch fluoride wer liebt also
ich oder die anderen nämlich de setzt
euch macht es euch gemütlich das wird
ein längeres video ich möchte hier auf
drei wissenschaftliche studien die einen
gegen die im zusammenhang florierte und
gehirn immer wieder zitiert werden nur
im gegensatz zu den vielen anderen
erwägungen anderswo werden wir hier
richtig ins detail gehen denn details
sind nun mal verdammt wichtig in der
wissenschaft aber wisst ihr warum er so
selten details über wissenschaftliche
studien erfahrt weil die meisten
wissenschaftsjournalisten und
medienmacher glauben das interessiert
niemanden und oder das steht dir sowieso
keiner sollte ein schnurrbart sein weil
sie nicht gemerkt so etwas aber das
glaube ich nicht ich glaube ihr habt auf
dieses video geklickt weil ihr ganz
genau wissen wollt was jetzt mit diesen
flügen ist und ich traue ich natürlich
zu dass euch das nicht zu kompliziert
ist also tschüss let's go nummer eins
die element studie element steht für die
live exposures in mexiko twente toxic
welchen einfluss haben verschiedene
schadstoffe aus der umwelt auf die
gesundheit von kindern in mexiko-city
sehr große langzeitstudie ein fokuspunkt
war zum beispiel blei aber diese studie
hat sehr viele verschiedene
veröffentlichungen herausgebracht unter
anderem eine zufrieden und zwar man hat
frieden proben von insgesamt 500
schwangeren gesammelt und den
fluoridgehalt indem er ihn bestimmt also
je mehr fluorid im urin ist desto mehr
hat man auch zu sich genommen frage gibt
es jetzt einen zusammenhang zwischen dem
fluoridgehalt im urin der mutter und der
intelligenz des kindes
hier sind die ergebnisse fangen wir an
mit dem ergebnis der vierjährigen auf
der xa
sie ist die konzentration von florid im
urin der mütter auf der y-achse steht mc
pg 24 einfach gesagt entspricht das dem
iq der kinder die abfallende linie heißt
je mehr fluorid das thema die kinder
wir sehen aber auch dass die daten sehr
stark streue dieser grau unterlegte
bereich ist der sogenannte
konfidenzintervall in diesem fall heißt
das wenn man dieses experiment jetzt
noch ganz oft wiederholen würde dann
wäre die wahrscheinlichkeit dass der
mittelwert innerhalb dieses grauen
bereich liegt 95% und wir sehen hier mit
steigender florid konzentration 4 dietz
messung immer ungenauer
das sieht man darin dass der graue
bereich immer breiter wird
schauen wir weiter auf die ergebnisse
der sechs bis zwölfjährigen selber
auftragen fluorid konzentration gegen
den iq der kinder bei den älteren
kindern sehen wir jetzt was anderes bis
zu einem gewissen wert nämlich etwa ein
milligramm fluorid pro liter hat das
studiert gar keinen einfluss auf die
intelligenz erst bei einer höheren
konzentration gilt wieder je mehr florid
desto dümmer die kinder wir haben es
also hier mit einem nicht linearen
zusammenhang zu tun es geht nicht
einfach so sondern es geht so dabei gibt
es aber für diese höheren fluorid
konzentration auch nicht so viele daten
wie ihr seht die messe mit ungenaue was
man zum beispiel auch wieder an den
breiteren grauen konfidenzintervall
sieht fazit ja wir jetzt wohl mehr
details kennt ist es gar nicht mehr so
einfach zu ziehen richtig und das ist ja
auch das undankbare war
wissenschaftsjournalismus die leute
wollen immer höheren fluorid ist sicher
favorit ist giftig für differenzierung
hat die heutzutage keiner mehr zeit
außer ihr natürlich deswegen seit ich
hier
die autoren selbst also die
wissenschaftler die diese studie
geschrieben haben sind selbst der
meinung dass schwangere keinen größeren
mengen an fluorid ausgesetzt werden
sollte gleichzeitig räumt sie aber
selbst die grenzen ihrer eigenen studie
und ich werde es euch mal zeigen nur
damit ihr den unterschied versteht
zwischen einem populärwissenschaftlichen
beitrag und einem wissenschaftlichen
artikel
ganze fünf abschnitte widmen die
wissenschaftler allein den verschiedenen
faktoren welche die aussagekraft ihrer
ergebnisse beeinträchtigen
trotzdem kann man und sollte man von
solchen ergebnissen praktische
konsequenzen ableiten zum beispiel indem
man sich fragt sollte man trinkt wasser
noch extra mit fluorid versetzen in
deutschland wird das sowieso nicht
gemacht aber in anderen ländern wo das
gemacht wird zur breiten
kariesprophylaxe wird das ganze auch neu
diskutiert das heißt jetzt ganz jetzt
aber für die zahnpasta nichts es geht
hier um eine systemische aussetzung eine
systemische verabreichung von fluiden
über die nahrung übers wasser und nicht
über eine lokale wie beim zähneputzen wo
man das meiste wieder ausspuckt sehr
wichtiger unterschied denn ich kann es
nicht oft genug sagen die dosis macht
das gift nummer zwei die chinesische
metern
wie sagt man so schön eine studie ist
keine studie deswegen schauen wir uns
jetzt eine sogenannte meta analyse an
meta analyse heißt man vergleicht viele
verschiedene studien zum selben thema
und fasst die ergebnisse in dieser viel
zitierten metaanalyse ging es um 16
verschiedene chinesische studien die
einen zusammenhang zwischen fluorid und
der intelligenz von kindern untersuchen
china mit allerlei umweltverschmutzungen
zu kämpfen fluorid kontamination von
trinkwasser ist eine davon zumindest in
manchen regionen beim zusammenfassen von
diesen 16 studien kamen auf einen
durchschnittlichen iq verlust von fast 5
punkten in regionen mit erhöhter florid
konzentration
das ist ganz schön erschreckt aber es
gibt immer eine aber erstmal die meisten
studien vergleichen hier regionen mit
viel fluorid versus region mit wenig
florid aber wir fahren jetzt leider gar
nicht wieviel jetzt viel ist und wieviel
wenig und noch etwas räumen die autoren
selbst
diese metaanalyse ist nur bedingt
repräsentativ woran sieht man dass diese
pyramide hier ist ein statistisches tool
und nennt sich funnel pott jeder dieser
punkte steht für eine der 16 studien die
hier zusammengefasst wurden ich will
kürze jetzt mal sehr stark aber im
prinzip sagt und so ein fanal plot
folgte je symmetrische aussieht also
beziehungsweise je mehr er so aussieht
wie jetzt hier bei wikipedia desto
repräsentativer ist die metaanalyse das
ist hier nicht der fall der fahne plot
ist nicht symmetrisch das heißt hier
scheint es irgendein bei es zudem sprich
irgend eine systematische verzerrung
irgendein systematischen fehler und das
geben die autoren auch selbst zu
deswegen gab es später eine neuere
meta-analyse mit optimierter methodik
erster blick auf den chart zeigt schon
mal ein symmetrisches bild außerdem
wurden hier jetzt nicht nur 16 sondern
27 studien miteinander wirklich jetzt
achtung sind es nicht mehr fünf iq
punkte sondern nur noch 0,45 punkte
weniger durch bringt das ist natürlich
ein wesentlicher unterschied und die
autoren selbst sagen auch dass dieser
unterschied nicht riesig ist aber
natürlich sollte man auch nicht den
kleinsten eu verlust von ganzen
bevölkerungsgruppen riskieren ist klar
nur auch hier kann man schon wieder
leider keine aussage über die kritische
dosis machen da nicht bekannt ist wie
viel fluorid die kinder nun tatsächlich
eingenommen haben
fazit fluorid kontamination von
trinkwasser stellt ein ernsthaftes
risiko für die intelligenz von kindern
da betrifft das hier das zähneputzen
nein auch wenn man die genauen zahlen
nicht kennt so weiß man zumindest dass
die fluorid konzentration in der umwelt
in diesen chinesischen regionen in ganz
anderen größenordnungen liegen als sie
es in deutschland sind und zweitens fand
es sich hier wieder um eine systemische
verabreichung von frieden und keine
lokale wie beim zähneputzen dann gibt es
natürlich auch tierstudien wo mäusen und
ratten hohe fluorid konzentration
systemisch verabreicht wurden auch hier
man toxizitäten festgestellt sehen diese
studien aussagekräftig sind sie aber
relevant fürs zähneputzen nein nummer 3
lux zirbeldrüse studie kommen wir
endlich zur zielbild röse und der frage
ob floride die zirbeldrüse verhalten
die zirbeldrüse sitzt bei wirbeltieren
so ziemlich genau in der mitte des
gehirns und wird auch manchmal das
dritte auge genannt was weniger
esoterisch ist also zunächst klingt
zumindest für fische reptilien und
amphibien bei denen die zirbeldrüse
tatsächlich so ähnlich wie unsere
netzhaut direkt lichtempfindlich ist bei
säugetieren oder bei menschen ist sie
nur indirekt lichtempfindlich durch eine
connection zum auge einer ihrer
wichtigsten aufgaben ist die produktion
des schlafhormons melatonin und spielt
eine rolle in unserer inneren uhr dazu
haben wir auch schon mal ein altes schön
schlau video gemacht der linke so die
zis ist prinzipiell ein weiches organen
kann aber auch stellen von mineralen
bild man sagt dazu
galifi zierung glaube ich also sagt man
das auf deutsch so casey fiction die
zirbeldrüse verkalkt also tatsächlich es
bilden sich kleinere mineralisierte
regionen mineralien die in ihrer
zusammensetzung ganz ähnlich sind zu
unseren zähnen oder zu unseren knoch
also ein kalzium haltiges mineral wir
wissen bis heute immer noch nicht was
dieser verkalkungen auslöst und ob das
was schlechtes ist oder ein ganz normale
natürliche und harmloser prozess es
besteht verdacht auf zusammenhang mit
krankheiten wie alzheimer
die forschung ist hier noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen ich persönlich hatte das
zumindest nicht für ausgeschlossen zumal
alzheimer soweit ich weiß auch was mit
männer tun ihn spiegeln zu tun hat wenn
sich für idee in unseren zahnschmelz
einbauen können wie wir bei unseren
karies video gelernt haben dann könnte
ich diese floride doch sicherlich auch
in den mineralen in der zirbeldrüse ein
bahn hinzukommen dass die zielgröße
außerhalb der blut-hirn-schranke liegt
also während der rest des gehirns nicht
so zugänglich für vier regionen ist ist
die zirbeldrüse prinzipiell offen für ex
ist sowie zu den allgemeinen infos es
gibt kaum studien die sich mit der
zirbeldrüse und fluiden beschäftigen
außer diese von florid kritikern oft
zitierte studie von jennifer sie hat
sich elf leichen geschnappt und
folgendes gemessen wie viel fluorid
befindet sich in den knochen in den
muskeln und in der zirbeldrüse dieser
elf leichen ist ist jetzt keine
statistisch überwältigende zahl aber
schauen wir mal was da raus kam hier ist
ja fluoridgehalt in der zirbeldrüse ging
den kalziumgehalt in der zirbeldrüse
aufgetragen der kalziumgehalt steht
stellvertretend für den grad der
mineralisierung also je mehr kalzium
sich in der zielgröße befindet desto
mehr mineral befindet sich dort also
desto mehr verkalkung haben die hier
vorliegen was hier gefunden wurde war
ich mehr kalzium desto mehr floritz fall
zum scheint also zum beispiel fluorid
anzuziehen oder andersrum an der
streuung der messpunkte sieht man das
ist jetzt nicht der genaueste
zusammenhang mehr als elf werden hier
sicherlich hilfreich aber ich nehme das
ergebnis so hin denn positive
korrelation ist definitiv da diese traf
sagen jetzt aber leider nicht ob fluorid
sich erst in der zirbeldrüse anreichert
und dann kalzium anzieht und dadurch die
verkalkung initiiert oder ob es
andersrum ist das ein hoher
kalziumgehalt in der zirbeldrüse für
region anzieht das weiß man jetzt nicht
kraft nummer zwei wir vergleichen hier
den relativen fluoridgehalt in knochen
mit dem relativen fluoridgehalt im ziel
und wir sehen in neun der elf fälle ist
der favorit gehalt in der zirbeldrüse
relativ gesehen höher als im klub das
kann natürlich daran liegen dass die
minerale in der zirbeldrüse kleiner sind
und dadurch eine größere relative
oberfläche haben und verriet baut sich
eben ihnen der oberfläche ein wenn wir
also relativ gesehen mehr oberfläche
abend macht das sehen dass wir relativ
gesehen auch mehr florida ist für mich
persönlich also sehr logisch und
nachvollziehbar aber ich sehe jetzt hier
auch wieder keine aussage darüber ob
floride jetzt der grund für die
verkalkungen sind oder nicht fazit
halten fest fluorid kann sich offenbar
in der zielgröße genauso einbauen wie
einem zahlen
zweitens da die relative oberfläche viel
höher ist ist auch der relative
fluoridgehalt in der zirbeldrüse
richtung
wir wissen jetzt dass zum beispiel in
der kariesprophylaxe die zähne durch
chlorid ein bisschen härter und
beständiger werden man kann davon
ausgehen dass dasselbe auch für die
minerale in der zirbeldrüse geht die
frage ist jetzt nur ob das die mineral
bildung überhaupt es verursacht oder
begünstigt das wissen wir wie gesagt
leider nicht folgendes kommt auch noch
hinzu in vielen tieren werden
zirbeldrüse verkalkung und beobachtet
und in menschen in verschiedenen
bereichen der welt sieht man keine
besonders großen unterschiede was diese
verkalkungen betrifft wenn zum beispiel
das floriert aus der zahnpasta
verkalkungen hervorrufen würde warum
haben dann auch tiere verkalkungen in
der zielgröße wenn es jetzt nicht einer
zahnpasta sondern zb am grundwasser am
trinkwasser liegt wo vielleicht zu viel
fluorid drin ist warum sehen wir dann
keine globalen regionalen unterschiede
wo wir doch wissen dass sich für ried
konzentration in verschiedenen regionen
sehr stark unterscheiden können und doch
was wenn ihr studien findet die sich mit
toxizität und florin beschäftigen dann
schaut bitte auf zwei sachen nämlich
erstens die konzentration und zweitens
die art und weise der exposure also
lokal beim zähneputzen oder durch essen
und trinken zähneputzen mit frieden ist
sicher es gibt keinen wissenschaftlichen
grund dafür
was anderes anzunehmen und für alle die
jetzt so etwas geschrieben haben wie ich
putze seit jahren ohne für ide und habe
nie carius gut für ernsthaft wenn du
kein klares bekommst dann brauchst doch
keine floride dann musste auch keine
benutzen der körper braucht ihr keine
floride aber wenn ihr karies an fertig
seid und ihr habt angst vor florin in
der zahnpasta tut durch den gefallen
nutzt eure zähne mit florin und erspart
euch schmerzhafte zu haben und wie
gehört unserem trinkwasser wird kein
story zugesetzt und das finde ich auch
nicht notwendig jeder kann sich ja
selber die zähne putzen wenn er möchte
aber es gibt salz das floriert ist und
es gibt auch mineralwasser
flori drin ist da könnte ja gerne
einfach mal drauf achten und schauen ob
ihr auf die 0,05 milligramm pro
kilogramm körpergewicht pro tag kommt
das ist die offizielle empfohlene dosis
auch für kinder und schwangere freunde
wenn ihr dieses video bis hierhin
geschafft
sag mir bescheid wenn ihr das ganze
video gesehen habe dann kriegt die
nämlich von mir persönlich ja es ist
wieder krieg style ein pixi ohne karies
gefragt überprüft außerdem das was ich
euch heute alles erzählt habe mit den
links in der video beschreibung wir
sehen uns nächsten donnerstag bis dahin
bleibt sicher
das schien
shit schaffen
[Musik]
ich glaube das war's